the printing press was incredibly
revolutionary
in all sorts of ways nobody talks about
like that 50 to 75 year period when the
predictors first came about and it was
just like
madness and revolution and insanity and
all sorts of crazy things happen and it
took a while
for society to sort of come to terms
with the fact that like okay
the monopoly that there used to be on
printing
is now gone and i think we're going
through something in the same thing
right now
following last week's attack on the u.s
capitol by a pro-trump mob
twitter permanently banned the president
of the united states from its platform
and facebook and youtube suspended his
accounts
meanwhile parlor which marketed itself
as a more open alternative to twitter
was booted from the apple and google app
stores and
amazon web services evicted the company
from its cloud computing platform
is the great deep platforming of 2021 a
threat to free speech
or should we think of twitter as a
christian bakery and trump as a gay
wedding cake as one user of that
platform quipped
meaning that nobody should be able to
force a private company to do business
with someone it disagrees with
enter mike masnick the 46 year old
entrepreneur and analyst behind the
influential website
tech dirt and the digital think tank the
copia institute
where others are constantly talking
about how to restrict and regulate the
internet and tech giants to conform to
one ideological vision or another
masnic champions protocols and practices
that he thinks would lead to a more
decentralized internet and culture
including expanding section 230
widespread encryption
and tools that give end users rather
than political and cultural
commissars even more power to control
what we say and see online
reason spoke with masnic about what
current debates over social media get
drastically wrong how free speech has
simultaneously
empowered and imperil by politicians
here and abroad
and why a more decentralized internet is
not just possible
but preferable to what we have now
mike masnick thanks for talking to
reason yeah thanks for having me
all right we're going to talk about
section 230 we're going to talk about
d-platforming
re-platforming un-platforming and
eventually we're going to get to talk
about your fantastic 2019 essay for the
knight foundation protocols not
platforms which is about uh getting to a
decentralized or a more decentralized
internet um but first let me start off
with something that you wrote
recently after you know and i you know i
say recently
last week seems like a year ago you know
and
i don't know you know like 2010 seems
like a thousand years ago
but you wrote last week i guess i think
on friday or something when
trump had been kicked off at this point
of facebook and of twitter
um you wrote trump is perhaps the
perfect example of why demanding clear
rules on social media and how they
moderate
is stupid what do you mean by that
yeah i mean it's it's you know there's a
lot of context that goes into that and
it's part of a larger discussion
that i think um you know almost and
everybody
who um is coming at this debate with
solutions that say this is right this is
wrong
uh or anything along those lines um
generally hasn't thought these issues
through
and and hasn't realized um
not that these decisions are difficult
but that they are impossible and this is
something that i've sort of tried to
drive
home through various conversations that
i've had um
that you know for people who have to
make
moderation decisions they have a bunch
of choices in front of them
including do nothing and all those
choices are bad
all those choices have consequences um
and so there is no right answer and i
think that that a lot of people and this
is across the political spectrum
in all sorts of different ways and with
all sorts of different backgrounds
people think that there is a sort of
correct way to do it
uh whether that's like if we get the
the algorithm which you know we won't
say the formula but the algorithm
correct
we just have to put it into you know
insert it into the internet and then
everything will
be and it gets beyond that right there's
certainly a lot of that and there is
this sort of you know
techno solutionism idea that like yes
there will be an algorithm and it will
fix things
but then there are also the people who
say don't they shouldn't do anything
just completely hands off and that that
will be the the proper answer um and
you know very few people seem willing to
recognize that every one of these
solutions has
consequences and many of those
consequences are things that that
the vast majority of people would
consider to be negative and harmful
and and problematic um and so
you know i i spend a lot of time talking
to the trust and safety teams
um at the big companies at the small
companies you know i have some
you know marginal amount of experience
with just managing the
the community attack dirt itself um and
what you begin to realize is that you
know everything
is is constantly in flux and the idea of
setting up very clear rules
becomes impossible really quickly
because as soon as you have a rule
someone's going to figure out a loophole
or how to break the rule in a way that
looks like they're not breaking the rule
and so i was trying to get that across
with the statement regarding trump
because
so much of what the reality is is that
the context beyond just the content of
what they're saying
the context in which it is happening is
really
important and trump is a perfect example
of that because there's all sorts of
things in the world and nobody has a
rule in place that says well how do you
deal with
the president after a bunch of his
supporters have stormed the capitol
um that you write though um so i mean is
is twitter a better place in in the same
piece you wrote
you know trump is not being limited uh
he's not
you know and uh reason is a libertarian
outfit we've been this way since 1968 so
i'm going to insist on the tedious
definition you know that censorship kind
of per se can only be done by the
government so
you know twitter is a private company it
has an absolute right to
be as bad as they want to be in creating
terms of service and either
enforcing them or not all of that kind
of stuff but when you say trump is not
being limited
you're not talking in in you know kind
of jesuitical or legalistic terms
i i think what i said was that he's not
being censored and i was using it in
in that same sense as you were and that
he has many outlets for speech and in
fact probably more outlets than almost
anyone else
in the world right i mean he can you
know say what he wants to say
he can go on tv at the drop of a hat and
you know most
networks and cable news will broadcast
it
and clips of that will spread onto
you know twitter and you know within
seconds he could put up a page
on whitehouse.gov that are all of his
tweets
and people would repeat them on twitter
he has you know
many many methods to get his voice out
there he has 74 million people
right who you know who i mean it's a
fraudulent election so we can't be
certain they voted for him but
you know appear to have voted for him
right but he so he is not being
censored what about for smaller voices
and smaller outlets is
does trump's banning have any impact do
you think on on
on you know people further down the uh
the food chain
i i don't think that there's a direct
impact i think i think the
the larger concern that you're raising
is something that is worth thinking
about and talking about in terms of
you know how much access
and and who gets access to these
platforms is something we're thinking
about
um you know and and sort of how how that
plays out
uh and that's a lot of the other stuff
that i've written about but i don't
think that the
the trump situation in particular has
any direct impact again like
you know the context of the decisions
around trump are very specific
and and very much you know that context
is limited to one person in the world
and and it is donald trump and so um i
don't see how it like
changes anything in a manner that that
has a wider impact
beyond like you know don't get
you know millions of people to storm the
capital
um or even dozens or hundreds right well
more broadly do you think is is this i
guess in the biggest picture possible
is this a good time for free speech
because on the one hand
you have things like it it seems as if
every tech or social media platform is
tightening the screws they're at least
going through me you know uh
you know i mean twitter got rid of so
you know by their account of something
like 70
000 q anon adjacent or direct accounts
and all of that kind of stuff this purge
um you see footage everywhere you know
of antifa in portland blockading
you know powell's the greatest book
story in america left in america was
shut down because
people were saying uh you know you they
shouldn't be selling a particular book
online
you know so on on the one hand there
seems to be this paroxysm of
uh contraction of speech or of outlets
where you can just say whatever the hell
you want
on the other hand you know we're still
like living in a world that was
unimaginable even 10 years ago much less
20 or 30 years ago
is this a good time for free speech yeah
i mean i think i think it's
it is undeniable that this is probably
the best time there's ever been for free
speech
even recognizing all of that right i
mean you talk about you know there are
these limitations on these platforms
that
most people didn't have you know 10 15
20 years ago
right none of this existed go back 30
you know 40 years ago where where the
internet was
was in its you know infancy and and
people had no
outlets whatsoever for speech whereas
now they have tremendous outlets for
speech
the fact that a few of those platforms
and and certainly some of the most
popular ones and the ones that people
tend to rely on the most have sort of
pushed back or cut back
uh on some you know uh
segment of their accounts i don't think
is
an attack or harmful for free speech on
its own
you know is something like facebook
twitter
are they increasingly kind of erratic
and arbitrary in the way that they are
enforcing
you know whatever restrictions or
whatever guide you know guardrails
they're putting up
yeah i mean i think that that i don't
think that's a fair statement i think
it's one that a lot of people will make
and from the
outside and i'm you know one of the
people on the outside i'm certainly not
on the inside of these companies
i think that it may appear that way i
think the reality is
is often a lot more complicated and
again it gets back to that issue
of you know what i said with trump which
is that
you know to some extent the rules have
to keep changing because the situations
keep changing and the context keeps
changing
and so they appear arbitrary
in the sense that the context around
these decisions keeps changing and no
two examples are exactly the same so
people like to point out like
so-and-so got banned but so-and-so
didn't get banned or so-and-so said this
and somebody else said this which i say
is exactly the same and one person got
in trouble for it and the other person
didn't
but usually the context between all of
those
is very different and who is saying it
whether they're in a position of power
or not
whether or not they're you know uh uh
you know standing in front of people
storming the capital is
is different than somebody random saying
something
um and so there's there's a lot of
context there that
make may make it look arbitrary if you
ignore the context
but in reality i don't think is entirely
arbitrary
what about uh you know the uh um
amazon web services kind of delisting
um parlor you know the the i don't know
what we want to call it a kind of
alternative social media site or
platform
uh that was big with conservatives it
had a big surge in um
in subscription supposedly uh in the
fall because
it seemed like twitter and facebook were
kind of getting more and more
ideologically stringent
um aws said you know what we're we're
not hosting you anymore
is that uh and in some of your writing
you said you know these are
you know it's one thing when it when a a
platform or an app like twitter or
facebook does something
when you're talking about the kind of
hosting things that's a different type
of question
what is the distinction there yeah i
mean the way i've sort of been
trying to distinguish it and think about
it is that there is a difference between
sort of edge providers which are
the the consumer facing services that
you and i use every day
and then i refer to as infrastructure
like levels
and that's that goes many layers deep
you know beyond
the stuff that we see every day and i
think that there are a lot more
questions
that need to be thought about when it
comes to how the infrastructure
level players do these kinds of things
um
and and again this may depend on a whole
bunch of other factors including what
level of the infrastructure we're
talking about
because aws which is hosting cloud
services
is one thing um you know uh domain
registrar
is another you know your own internet
access is another
there are all these different levels and
you know
from a um you know straight up
perspective
uh of does amazon have the right to kick
off any customer
absolutely that's you know part of the
way this works their business they have
they can refuse service from anyone
um but you know it it becomes a bigger
question and
from a few different perspectives and
one that i really do want to think about
is when we see things like this where
will the government get involved at some
point
because the government keeps trying to
get involved in these content moderation
debates
and i worry a lot that they see
something like aws
pulling down parlor and saying aha
there's a
there's a ratchet there's a tool that we
can use
and when the government gets involved
you know
in some very very narrow cases the
government can
can force certain speech that is not
protected to come down because it is not
protected
but when they go to something like
amazon and not that they have yet but if
they do
and say this needs to be taken down then
you're talking about taking down
that prior restraint taking down a ton
of of protected speech
and so like there was some of that and
in fact like uh representative ro khanna
on twitter
on friday spoke out and said amazon
should take down parlor
and even if you think that amazon should
and even if you think that they can
legally which they can
the fact that a sitting congressman
suggested that i think is a reason to
sign up for parlor
and you know petition amazon to keep it
up absolutely i mean
you know well this is one of the things
that i i find
you know particularly maddening is the
way all of the positions
that almost everybody takes just seem to
be completely situational
so that you know you have conservatives
who a couple years ago were talking
about how like no
baker ever should have to even think
about cracking an egg to you know if
it's going to end up
you know they would abort eggs if they
were going to end up in a gay marriage
cake
you know no way and now they're saying a
private company has to be
you know forced to keep hosting stuff
that they don't want
and and the reverse is exactly the same
and it's it's just it's crazy-making
um and i mean how do how does this kind
of stuff just to stay on this kind of
infrastructure deal
you know how does that deal with um
certain types of say email providers
email service providers who i don't know
i remember a couple of years ago when
people like edward snowden
and chelsea manning and you know the
those were the issues of the day
and email services that said we're going
to encrypt everything and we
we refuse to have anything to do with
that and the government comes a knocking
and saying give us
the keys to this give us excuse that it
seemed like the conversation was very
different
and everybody at least kind of on the
broadly defined
left uh and the libertarian you know
whatever we are
were you know consistent or you know
unified and saying like
the government should never be allowed
to do that really um now that
you know now if we're talking about
hosting services it's almost like you
have a moral duty to get rid of
any like to tell amazon you know this
person
who might have like a clad account with
you or you know google drive
you know my old you know my
ex-girlfriend has some hateful things on
me
about me on that so that you should you
should cancel them i mean
yeah can you just kind of walk through
how how do you how do you get to some
clarity on this type of stuff
yeah i mean it's tricky is the answer is
that there there isn't necessarily a
you know a good answer i mean i think
that again like
private businesses in most of these
cases do have the right to decide who
they want to associate with when they
they have to make a calculation and
you know is it worth associating with
certain people or certain activities um
and that could be harmful for their
business and so i think it's entirely
acceptable and reasonable for them to
to make other decisions um you know
and and to some extent like the people
who are asking for
you know i will make it very clear
outside of elected officials which i
think are in a different category
um general people who are speaking out
and saying like hey
uh amazon you need to do this or hey
google you need to do this
that's their free speech rights as well
right and so it's part of the debate and
it's part of the conversation whether or
not we we like it and so
i think that's fine i think it's
important to think through these things
and i think
it would be nice to have a you know
wider more thoughtful
less reactive discussion and debate
about what are the pros and cons of
these different approaches and honestly
for the companies themselves how should
you be thinking
through this and again like not to say
these are the rules and if you
you know you have to set these rules
because you know
the situations as they play out will
never fit into those rules in particular
or very rarely or when they do like
those are the easy cases
the the cases that make the news and
that are important are the ones that
don't fit into those rules
but having a set of principles and how
do we think through this and how do we
make these determinations
i think becomes important and it'll be
really useful to have that conversation
yeah and i
i agree completely and also detaching
them from
you know the next three weeks of
legislative battles and
or perceived legislative battles in dc
would be helpful
um what it um you know what about the
fact that say a company like amazon
um you know their web services are one
thing
uh but then they're also they're
operating in a political marketplace
they're operating in you know a million
political marketplaces so that
uh you know how um are we reaching a
point where
you know the analysis of how a tech
giant like
amazon facebook etc happens it's like
well
amazon is thinking about what what's the
next tax break or the
the next tax policy they want that is
beneficial to their other business
you know are they are they swapping off
like we're going to give you this on
this end because of that
i'm thinking back to when comcast picked
up uh you know nbc and whatnot
and suddenly you have a cable provider
that's involved in
you know telephony plus broadcast
television which is actually regulated
by the government
um you know and you know that they're
you know at some level they're thinking
we
you know we're gonna we're gonna give
you know uh
i don't i don't know what part of the
comcast the ecosystem was czechoslovakia
or something
yeah i mean i it's tough to tell right i
mean with any big company there's a
whole bunch of different factors at play
you know i think that that there are
within all of these companies contrary
you know there are a lot of people who
believe like when it comes to like
facebook and twitter that it's like
jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg sitting
there saying you're blocked you're
blocked you're blocked you're allowed
you're
it's not how it works right you can see
uh dorsey stroking that beard that's
right
you know that weird house of david
baseball team beard yeah
yeah um but you know and and you know
but you're saying these are these are
like unbelievably messy
empires and i think it was something i
can't remember
you or somebody else at tech who was
saying that like
you know there's a lot of reason to
believe that it's like you know kind of
like
mid-level junior uh you know members of
a of a team that are really calling the
shots here that um
you know the top brass they don't know
what the hell is going on yeah and it's
you know and it's interesting you know
in most cases obviously like the biggest
cases i'm sure
you know the the top brass you know the
decision to
to to take donald trump's account down
was not made by a low-level person or
you know jack dorsey's you know his
desire to be in what like uh
burmese meditation retreats turning a
blind eye to rohingya problems
yeah you know that's probably in the
c-suite right there's there
you're right there there are issues um
but
um yeah i mean a lot of the choices are
made and and you have
you know conflicting opinions and again
like these are situations where
there are no right answers and and you
know we did this i've written about this
you know we did the this experiment a
few years ago at a content moderation
conference that was like all content
moderation trust and safety experts
where we gave them eight case studies
and they had a vote on like what would
you do
in this situation and there were about a
hundred people who
who participated and they all disagreed
with each other and these are the
the experts right and you're like yeah
we chose cases that maybe were a little
bit challenging but the fact is that
like
you know within these companies you have
that same disagreement and you have
different people pushing on
on different things and i know like you
know there's one trust and safety
um you know executive that i know who
says like he tries to think of it as
like conducting a trial
within the company when it comes to the
big the big decisions at least is he
says you know he sets up somebody you
advocate for
keeping this person you advocate for for
shutting them down and let's have this
sort of you know courtroom uh
set up where we can actually you know
advocate on each side and then come to a
decision
because sooner or later you're going to
make a decision and and that always
takes me back to the fact that like
you know you look at at the court system
itself and that's an example of
of these kinds of debates that you know
play out in you know
about the law and about some of these
issues you know
at a legal level and you see like
decisions are made they get overturned
on appeal
you know or or decisions are made that
lots of people disagree with
but you know for the most part you know
we we don't treat them the same way that
we treat the the content moderation
decisions it's like
you know maybe that's because they're
sort of in a black box and you don't
really see how the deliberations are
going and there's not necessarily the
transparency there
um but you know these things are really
really difficult and
and there are reasonable arguments for
all different positions
and yet people automatically jump to the
idea that there's like some sort of
nefarious
plot behind all these decisions well you
know though um
do you worry you know when you talk
about the court system is by
design is adversarial um it seems as if
there's
you know more speech being given or more
people are saying that
within corporate culture whether it's
you know wall street or whether it's
silicon valley or wherever
hollywood that there is a growing you
know sensibility that
we're not we're not being adversarial
here we you know that some
either all of the workforce that is woke
or whatever
there's a or or is reactionary you know
that we
know what is right and we're going to
enforce that uniformly as opposed to
have that kind of
robust internal discussion do you think
that that's mostly
um you know a kind of rhetorical battle
or do you think
there is something shifting um again you
know i
and i i was going through a bunch of
tech dirt stuff
a fantastic site that i highly recommend
anybody who's interested in the internet
broadly speaking and what used to be
called digital culture
check out but you were you know the the
the silicon valley people are no longer
classical liberal or libertarian in
their
you know in their commitments it seems i
do do you think something is changing
in the you know the broad-based culture
of silicon valley
towards a more focused univocal
uh expression of beliefs within a system
i don't think that's true i mean i i can
see where they're
i hope not yeah i i i think
that um you know
there are these are large companies for
the most part and there's they have a
variety of different people with a
variety of different
um you know backgrounds opinions
perspectives
um and you know some of the debates if
you actually get a chance to sort of
see how the debates play out there was
there was a a really good
i'm going to advertise somebody else's
podcast but the
radio lab a few years ago did the whole
episode about
facebook and their content moderation
efforts
that i thought was the most realistic
version i've seen of anyone discussing
how difficult these decisions are and
how you have this sort of back and forth
and um and pushing on on different
opinions and i think that
you know a lot of the trust and safety
professionals
are extraordinarily thoughtful about
these things
are not so ideologically driven as most
people seem to think they are
and are very very cognizant
of both the power
and the consequences of the decisions
that they make
and i know that like people don't
believe that and and again a lot of that
is because this is all happening behind
you know behind closed doors or whatever
um but there is a lot of careful thought
that goes into these decisions
um even if if we disagree with them i
think it's wrong to assume that it's
it's done either ideologically or
just you know totally arbitrarily do you
uh do you think that transparency
is the you know is is is a big uh
important factor that needs to kind of
be expanded or or is that just
you know people say that now and then
when they see how things are going to be
made they're going to be like no it's
still
it's wrong you know because really what
people want are outcomes they don't give
a [ __ ] about the process
it's it's it's a mixture right i mean
i'm always just generally supportive of
more transparency
uh because i think that's a good a good
thing to to work on
um but it's it's also one of these
things that that there are trade-offs
there as well and in fact you know i was
telling somebody recently
that you know on on techdirt we have
some some user voting systems that that
do the moderation
and the only people who've ever demanded
transparency about how that works for
the trolls who are trying to figure out
how to game the system
right so so you have this issue where
um transparency as a general principle
is always good
but you know what what do you need to be
transparent
about and why and when you're going to
have people who
whose main goal is to use that
transparency against you
i can see why companies you know
are are reticent to be super transparent
yeah and you know this is something i'm
a big fan of both michelle foucault and
friedrich hayek and
you know in different ways they both
talked about how you know what a
nightmare
to be i mean another word for
transparency is surveillance and like
sure
i just want a little bit of time to
myself and like i don't you don't have a
right to know why i think the way i do
so um and i i think the distinctions
that you you keep coming back to in your
work between
you know there is a difference between
kind of government power
and corporate power even if corporations
apparently have
you know monopolistic control of this or
that right or
you know the the how they maintain power
is is a little bit different um
can we talk about section 230 of the
communications
yes yes we must um because this is going
to be
in the news for at least another 24 to
48 hours so
um but um you know section 230 is
something that gets talked about a lot
people like on the on the right josh
hawley and ted cruz who conservative
republican senators
are against it donald trump was against
it to a point where he was going to hold
up
actually authorizing money for his
beloved pentagon
because he wanted section 230 to be
thrown out completely
uh and joe biden also a year less than a
year ago said i am going to get rid of
section 230 it's terrible it's got to be
gotten rid of
what is section 230 and why does it
drive people
more insane than you know than like uh
you know uh wasp songs from the 1980s
you know and and cyndi lauper and prince
songs drove the parents music resource
center nuts
uh yeah i mean uh and i know that you
guys have covered section 230
you know quite a lot on on reason you
know the basics of it is
it just says that that a website
is not responsible for is not
liable for third-party content that that
somehow
violates or infringes on the law so that
if somebody posts something
that that is defamatory is the the best
example they
are not liable for that with some
exceptions and
also related to that that those websites
have effectively freedom to moderate as
they see
fit um and that you know basically if
they are making moderation
choices the fact that they chose to
leave up some kinds of content does not
make them liable for that content so it
gives them freedom to choose
and to experiment and to change how they
moderate over time
right and and this is also in the i
guess jeff costa's
phrase or not phrase but the book titled
the 26 words that created the internet
right um you know this this essentially
allows for
social media as we know it uh a service
like yelp
would not exist if yelp was actually
responsible for every review
that somebody posted at that site the
same thing with facebook same thing with
twitter etc
so why is there so much conf well i
guess first
why are people against section 230 what
is what is joe biden's case against 230
and what is
ted cruz's i i think
almost everybody who is against section
230 either doesn't understand it or is
pretending not to understand it
because the the more you understand 230
generally speaking the more
you're going to say that it is not the
problem that you think you're dealing
with and so you have people like holly
and ted cruz and they're sort of arguing
on the side that
230 is why there is all this moderation
and they feel that that people who are
ideologically aligned to them or being
unfairly treated
online and this gets back to the
you know baking a cake example to some
extent where suddenly they flip their
position
um and yeah and they insist
that what like twitter and facebook etc
are either a publisher and then they're
responsible for everything or they're a
platform
and they are they're like the phone
company they can't
they can't tell people not to make phone
calls or not to talk about certain
things
and that's wrong right yeah i mean it's
so spectacularly wrong
i mean like the law doesn't say anything
it's it's 26 words long and it doesn't
mention that
and and and in fact like the law is
actually saying the exact opposite
right the law was put in place and and
deliberately so to to encourage
platforms to
to do moderation and in fact you know it
was in response to a case
you know against prodigy that where the
company wanted to set up family friendly
uh places and so they wanted to be able
to moderate their forums
and they got sued over content that was
left up and that was what inspired 230
and it was put in place by you know
bipartisan by a republican chris cox and
by a democrat ron wyden
and who believe that like having family
friendly spaces online
is a good value which you know seemed to
be sort of a traditional republican
value to some extent also
and and allowing the companies to
experiment and figure out how they
wanted to moderate was
was good policy um and so
and it's also it's kind of i mean i know
you guys have written a ton about this
i i will just leave it to listeners to
uh
google uh stratton oakmont and section
230 and there's a whole wolf of wall
street tie-in which is just
it's it's like a philip k dick novel
it's just it's too insane that somehow
that would happen and also the broader
kind of legislative history the
communications decency act of 1996 was a
terrible piece of legislation that
passed virtually
unanimously and the one thing that came
out of that was you know the one
i don't know phoenix that rose from the
ash because the supreme court overruled
virtually all of it was section 230
which is now
seen as the you know the lever of evil
for
everything that's bad about the internet
what what does
um so what is what is joe biden's kind
of case
against section two this is this is sort
of the opposite and it's always funny
that like
everybody hates it but for totally
opposite reasons
and so biden seems to believe as as a
bunch of people do incorrectly again
um and this is just as incorrect as as
hawley and
cruz's belief uh that because of 230
the platforms have no incentive to
moderate and therefore they turn a
blind's eye
to you know false information
uh you know fake news whatever you want
to call it
uh and so they don't they don't take
responsibility for this stuff so they
believe that if they take away section
230 it will create incentives for
the platforms to be more proactive and
to take responsibility for content
and it's not even clear that joe biden
will be able to get the internet on his
jitterbug phone right i mean this
well and and you know regardless of it's
not a partisan thing i i want to say
it's it's actually like an aegis thing
but
if the past couple of years of hearings
where they drag
you know silicon valley tech giant ceos
to washington
has proven anything it's that the people
running
making the laws about all of this stuff
have no [ __ ] clue
what's going on and and you know and
it's it's not even totally ageist and
because like you know
ron wyden is is a bit older yeah and and
he wrote the law and he still gets it
and he totally understands this stuff
and he spends a lot of time
correcting everybody else and i wish
more people would listen to him
because he's he seems to be the only
senator who fully understands the law
there are a couple people you know and
again like some democrats some
republicans who seem to understand the
the underlying factors here
and and plenty who don't um and so
you know i i wouldn't even say it's an
aegis thing i i i think it's just
you know who who wants to actually
understand how this works and who
doesn't
and just one quick point that i do want
to get back to because it comes up a lot
i mean
you mentioned like how how is it that
both sides now believe false things
about the law which is kind of
crazy when you think about it and and i
i think it might even
have something to do with with the the
title of jeff's book
not not it's not jeff's fault because he
didn't come up with that quote
as the 26 words that created the
internet but you know that that i forget
who exactly
that quote came from but it became sort
of commonly used
and i think people took that and through
like this weird sort of mental
transference
assume that if section 230 is the 26
words that created the internet
it is also responsible for all of the
bad things on the internet and therefore
if we get rid of
230 it'll somehow fix all the bad stuff
on the internet and that is a complete
and total misunderstanding
of 230 and also the first amendment and
how the internet works and how
human beings work and how societies work
can you
what what is your uh suggested um
you know way to address section 230 and
and again a detector you
you guys have published a number of
articles uh
and you are a publisher not a platform
right
so you actually yes uh well yeah i guess
so right because
you have comments so yeah uh um but
um you know talking about how it
actually most people
when you like think about it like their
problem isn't with section 230 the
problem is with the first amendment
because they're
they they are driven insane by speech or
expression that they disagree with
and that they don't even understand that
actually you know if you're if you're
saying something defamatory about
somebody you can be sued for that it's
just that you can't sue
twitter right necessarily and under
certain circumstances you can sue
the platform publisher whatever you want
to call it so
what is your fix or you know because you
you have also talked about how like
you know section 230 if not you know it
needs to be revised it needs to be
updated or you know how would you
improve
well you know there's a there's a few
different things there and and
i'll say that um
you know and i i should be clear like
when i say that the the problem is not
230 it's the first amendment
again that goes to both sides that are
getting this wrong right you do have the
people
who are really upset about speech that
they don't like that is perfectly
protected
and and they're upset about that and
they want that to disappear and then you
have on the other side
the people who are saying that like you
know twitter shouldn't be allowed to
moderate
or facebook shouldn't be allowed to
moderate that's an attack on the
first amendment rights of those
companies to not be compelled to whose
speech that they don't want so
their first amendment problems on both
sides in terms of the law 230 itself i
actually think that 230
you know doesn't really need to be
changed and i think you know every
you know i've had this question asked
and i want to write something on it soon
actually
um you know how would you refer reform
the law and i think there are a whole
bunch of other laws
that we should be looking at first if
your concerns are about
you know how much power certain
companies have there are other laws that
are
that are there if you're concerned about
types of content online and how it's
dealt with there are many other laws
that are much more important um to be
looked at than 230.
you know if anything and nobody agrees
with this so i'm all alone like i would
expand 230. you know i would
i would roll back the foster which was
the the only major reform that's been
done to 230 which i think has been
really harmful
and could you spell out what foster
slash
actually stands for yeah i forget what
the
full acronym is but but they were they
were
laws that you know uh section 230 has
been attacked from from all different
angles for for many years
and this was the first one that stuck
and the idea the idea was it was really
targeted at one site which was backpage
and again like reason has done like most
of the best reporting on
on the the the truth behind the back
page situation which was a
classified ad site that was accused of
being used for sex trafficking um
and you know the the it is often you
know prostitution or sex work
and sex trafficking get lumped together
which is unfair and wrong
um and so there were all these efforts
to take down backpage
and it was believed that because
backpage had won
one particular case on 230 grounds that
230 was the problem
so they created this law that basically
created an exemption
for um you know
sex trafficking content but very broadly
defined and in a very risky way and in
fact when that law passed what happened
was
a bunch of dating sites like just you
know normal legitimate dating sites shut
down
and even like craigslist shut down their
personals page
because they they felt the the liability
that came along with foster was too big
and in fact now we have seen some
lawsuits and
and honestly almost every lawsuit that
has come about since foster passed
almost three years ago
has been ridiculous i mean you know
salesforce got sued
because backpage used salesforce as
their crm
and so the argument is that like under
foster uh salesforce is now responsible
for
the fact that that somebody did sex
trafficking on
backpage um and you know there have been
all these stories now about how it's
made it harder for law enforcement to
actually
uh track down sex traffickers because
they don't have the information that
they had and in fact it's come out and
again like
this is reasons reporting ha you know
presented all this evidence about how
the doj
worked closely with backpage and relied
on backpage cooperation
to help bust sex trafficking rings um
and uh it is also there's been all this
evidence shown that it's put sex workers
uh at at much higher risk of not having
backpage or not having other forums
where they can
be safe and they can present themselves
in safe ways so i would roll that back
you know and then the other area that
section 230 doesn't cover is
intellectual property law
and for that we have the dmca which i
think is a much worse
solution for for copyright in particular
where
that has created real censorship and and
real problematic
uh attacks on free speech that nobody
seems to want to talk about in all these
debates which can you
explain yeah how does the digital
millennium copyright act again this
i feel like you know we're blowing the
dust off of the federalist papers or
something and that's
you know it's not that old but yeah how
does
the mca stifle uh free speech
sure so so the dmca and they're often
like lumped together dmca section 512
in in this case and cda230 are often
lumped together
um because they're both sort of
intermediary liability laws
but the the copyright one is very
different so for that
uh a website first needs to register
with the copyright office and there's a
whole
ridiculousness there that i won't get
into where they'll throw out your
registration every three years if you
don't renew
and you have to pay money and it's a big
mess but you have to register and then
if you've registered
if somebody sends a takedown notice
to your registered agent saying that
there is infringing
material you have to take it down
or you then can become liable and so
then they could see you if you take it
down
then you are protected but that raises
to me
these very serious first amendment
questions because you now have
the law basically creating tremendous
incentives for you to take down content
and what happens in reality and there's
tons of evidence of this
is that people send completely bogus
dmca takedown notices knowing that just
the risk of liability is going to get
that taken down so that becomes
you know the use of state power to
threaten a company
to take down content that may be
protected speech and so it is used all
the time
to uh take down protected speech and i
think that's a huge first amendment
problem and i think
that removing section 230 actually gets
you more and more towards that there
will probably be a kind of notice and
takedown
provision for other kinds of content and
so you'll get that same thing where tons
of protected content is taken down just
on the threat
of of potential litigation um and so
you know in an ideal world i would
extend 230 to cover copyright
information also
to say that you know you shouldn't have
to take content down
just on notice you can if you believe
it's infringing if you believe there's a
risk there
um but you know the structure of the
dmca i think is very problematic
um and so again let's go back to this
question of
you know on a you know on a very
profound level that we should never lose
sight of i think you know this is an
unbelievable period of free speech in
human history
um you know because pretty much anybody
anywhere can say whatever they want
uh you know whether it's on a street
corner or you know on some corner of the
internet
um but there does seem to be this kind
of
you know ongoing attempt to kind of
constipate
discussion uh both in kind of cultural
ways of saying like you know if you
to even ask that question is to re
reveal yourself as racist or homophobic
or this or that
or also legally to you know kind of
restructure
what is permissible um you know
are you optimistic like what what needs
to
uh is is there a kind of culture of free
speech that we need to
reinvigorate um
or is this the culture of free speech
yeah i mean i think there's
there's a mix and you know honestly some
of what we're
learning about now is is kind of like
the societal reaction to
more people being able to speak um and
it's it's one of the societal
changes that that everyone you know that
we we have to go through
and um you know i don't know if you know
clay shirky you've probably come across
his writings
at times and he wrote this thing many
years ago now and i it's got to be 10
15 years ago where he talked about like
the printing press and like the arrival
of the printing press and how
like it was incredibly revolutionary in
all sorts of ways
and people talk about before the
printing press and they talk about after
the printing press
and you know all of the the new things
that it created and obviously like you
know kicking off the reformation
and all sorts of uh you know all sorts
of other things
um but he says you know nobody talks
about like that 50 to 75 year period
when when the printing press first came
about and it was just like
madness and revolution and insanity and
and people were not happy with the
printing press and the fact that like
you know not just the church could
publish the bible anymore and like
all sorts of crazy things happen and it
took a while for
society to sort of come to terms with
the fact that like okay
you know the the the monopoly that there
used to be
on printing is now gone uh and i think
we're going through something in the
same thing right now
and you know in an even more profound
way and that anyone can speak
but that leads to some potential issues
and the question is how do we deal with
it as a society
and and you know i i find that the the
rush on sort of both sides whether it's
like
the people say like well the law has to
deal with this in some way
um which is you know which is happening
and certainly like on the european side
of things like that's very much their
focus they're trying to
legislate everything on this front and
then you have other people who are like
well the tech companies have to solve it
um i think that's missing the point too
and i think part of it is just like
society has to come to terms with this
and society has to understand this stuff
and so you know we have a lot of people
who are behaving badly
and i get that that's worrisome and
that's a that's a problem but like
you know that's a societal issue for us
to deal with how do we educate people
better how do we
you know teach people not to to believe
false information how do we teach people
to understand these things and how do we
teach people well we teach them to agree
completely with
me or you know or you or whoever um
how where does where do you come from uh
you know
and i asked this you know this is the
david copperfield
uh not the magic session but the david
the dickens
the david copperfield crap the
biographical moment
in in this conversation from your
linkedin uh
profile i i know that you went to
cornell in the
in the mid to late 90s you have a ba and
an m.a but
you know how old are you and where did
you you know why are you
why are you doing what you're doing why
why am i wired this way
um yeah i don't know that i have a good
answer to that i mean i
i grew up you know i i got my first
computer run
in 1980 when i was six years old uh and
do you remember what kind it was i got
an atari 800
which people don't remember but was
you know atari's entrance into the the
pc space and it had a keyboard
uh and a disk drive uh and we actually
had a a
cassette recorder right so you could
load programs from a cassette recorder
uh as well i had one of those that had
you would get i would get like the 120
minute long cassette tapes yeah i gave
you the best time but then whenever you
saved something it would be exactly
i'm going to walk around the block and
come back
and so you know so i got really into
computers uh and
and just loved technology and all the
things that it allowed
um and then you know i went to
to college in cornell and um and was
still just sort of you know
you know kind of a hobbyist very
interested in technology and the culture
around technology
um you know and and was reading all
different
things and like that must have been very
exciting though to be
your age and be in computers uh you know
during the 90s i mean because
at all that you know the everything you
know came to kind of fruition it seemed
yeah yeah and it was really interesting
and i had
i i really had two professors who i
think sort of set me on this path
um and um and one was alan mcadams
um who's a really interesting guy who's
a economist
and and had been uh in the nixon white
house of all things
uh and had been a government expert in
the ibm
anti-trust trial in the 80s and he had
this whole
idea about technology and innovation and
again this is like mid-90s
and he was really focused on like
open source uh
software um and he thought that like
microsoft and its
its um um you know proprietary software
was a problem
and that the world would be better off
with open source technology and more
sharing of information
and more widely accessible information
and so
you know i i worked very closely with
him um
and and learned a lot about sort of
where innovation could go
with more you know more open sharing of
information and just to give you an idea
of like how far back this is
you know in in the mid 90s where
everybody had dial up this is like the
very beginning of dsl technology if you
had a high speed it was like
a t1 line that cost you two thousand
dollars a month or whatever
um and he was arguing at the time you
can go back and find some of the
articles he he passed away
about a decade ago but um he had written
these articles saying that
we should have fiber to the home to
every home in america and we should be
that should be
you know as hugely important however it
gets done
whether you know through you know
private companies doing it whether the
government has to come in and subsidize
it
like the impact of having you know real
fiber access to everyone's home
would be completely revolutionary um
really
sort of interesting to experience in in
the 90s and to begin to think about like
how does information uh how does
information play into economics
which was like kind of a big thing where
like you know i'd always learned up to
that point the idea of like
economics being the study of you know
research allocation
and and scarcity right and information
effectively turns out on its head
because you no longer have the same sort
of scarcity
information being the type of thing you
know as like thomas jefferson family
said you know with the lighting the
candle i
if i have a candle and light yours now
we both have it we haven't we haven't
diminished we've
we've increased um and that creates all
these weird economic incentives that
you know for most of history nobody has
studied
and really only starting in about you
know the late 80s
to early 90s did economists begin to
really start to think about the impact
of
um you know non-scarcity of functions
yeah yeah on on economics and to me
that set me off on recognizing like the
power of information the power of
information
sharing and of technology um
to you know to create innovation and
growth
um and and that and and from there i've
just gotten
you know really focused on all sorts of
different discussions around that
but but at its core it's it's an
economic concept
of you know the economics of abundance
and your your main
gig is is i mean um explain
is tech dirt your main gig or is explore
64 your company which
provides information right to clients
yeah so it's it's a little bit complex i
mean
so it's all sort of associated 464 sort
of the the overall corporate name but it
has
techdirt as the blog and we do a bunch
of different things there
and then related to that is we have this
thing called the kopi institute which is
sort of a think tank
um that sort of tries to do more
interesting things around the type of
stuff that we write about at
tech dirt and so we do events we do
research
um one thing that we've been doing a lot
of the corporate espionage i
i assume right that's another word for
it but uh that's not that's not we did
get asked that in the early days we just
actually get asked to do that and i was
like that's really not what we're doing
but uh um but you know we
we've done research we've done research
reports either for public research
reports or
internally for for some folks um but one
thing we've done
lately which has been really interesting
is is actually sort of
building what we call games um just
recognizing that when people are doing
something
different um a game or something
of that nature it sort of takes them out
of their preconceived notions and allows
them to
to think of things in a different way
you know i talked earlier about
getting people to you know uh actually
have to answer how they would handle
certain content moderation decisions and
that's a perfect example of that
when you put people into the shoes of
the actual people who are making those
decisions
and then they begin to see you know
begin to see like oh these are really
challenging so like
we did one on like election
disinformation recently and like
how the election you know how different
factions might use disinformation
to to try and you know drive an outcome
regarding the election which has
suddenly become
certainly pretty relevant do you find
with the
you know the um advent of mass
information
um you know it really it really does
change everything and you know
thinking about the 90s i i'm 57 and i
started i bought my first
new car in 1996 and i used rudimentary
information that was online to i think
get a better deal
but 10 years later i actually was buying
cars
always cheap shitty cars but uh
completely online and i would just go
and pick it up
and it you know it's such a um
a case study of like how having more
information as a consumer like you can
just you get a better price
and also the car dealer like they're not
going to waste time
sweating you for stuff when they can
sell you a car for
you know in 15 minutes over you know for
a decent price over
on online instead of like you know they
don't have to work as hard
just so different but then there's this
question of like
you know kind of everybody has almost
everybody has
fiber optic or the equivalent coming
into their house or into their hands or
their phone
and they use that information very
differently and it doesn't seem
i mean i i guess what i'm asking is like
is some of the techno optimism or
techno utopianism of the 90s where
information will set us free
it doesn't quite do that it just kind of
it makes us all able to live how we want
but it kind of complicates things more
than
it ever settles anything doesn't it yeah
i mean
again like you know i see it in a few
different ways
and one of those is that you know
there's a societal issue right
i mean everyone has access to this stuff
it is a question of how they use it and
people have different
you know frameworks and and and thought
processes and and again like
the flood of information is something
that we haven't really learned to deal
with the abundance of information is
something that as a society we haven't
learned to deal with
and that's created problems you know
some people are able to process that and
some people are able to
to judge credibility um but that's a
skill and it's a skill that hasn't
really been taught
you know hopefully it's now starting to
be taught and people are starting to
understand it
but still the really really early days
and so i think over time
i'm i still remain optimistic that this
this will
you know will get to the right thing and
i certainly you know i'm often put into
that camp of sort of techno
techno-optimists or techno-utopians
and to some reason i don't think that's
fair because i've spent my whole life
basically you know arguing uh about
like you know against why we should we
we need to
ward off you know i'm not a utopian or
optimist in the sense that i think this
stuff is inevitable
um because i think you you sort of have
to fight for it if you want the
technology to work the way i think it
should over time
then i think that's worth fighting for
but i i recognize that it's not just the
technology
it's the societal questions as well and
that you know
the the literacy question having people
be able to understand this
give people the tools to to better
process things and to
to you know understand information flows
and what's credible and what to take
seriously and what not to
i you know and i i rush to say that i i
like the fact that there's more
information that people can kind of
create their own bubbles
because you're living in you're living
in a bubble one way or the other and if
it can
actually be reflective of your
subjective desires that's great
i like also i'm pulling out of what you
said i always talk about how we need
you know better media literacy because
there's so much more media but i think
actually we need information literacy
which takes it to a whole other level
and i agree with you that we're you know
it we think we're at the end of history
always but in fact
we're at the dot matrix uh this is a
really bad metaphor
but we're at the top matrix you know
stage
of kind of internet you know as society
and stuff like that we've got a long way
to go
um to that end you in 2019 you wrote a
fantastic
uh essay for i think was the knight
foundation a journalism group
or a media kind of literacy group
proficiency group uh
called protocols not platforms can you
sketch out
what your basic thesis there was and
sure is that still governing
kind of your broad vision of not of not
of the specifics but how we should be
thinking about
things like the internet yeah and and
just to clarify really quickly it's it's
actually the knight institute at
columbia
oh i'm sorry which is partly funded by
the knight foundation
but the knight institute at columbia is
a first amendment free speech
uh institute uh that does
litigation and writing stuff like that
and the knight foundation
is named after bobby knight of indiana
you know they just like to beat people
and things
yes with a chair
uh yeah so so the protocol is not
platforms paper which
came out of some of the other writings
that i had done on tech dr previously
and then
um you know the the knight institute
really asked me to to dig deep
and write a whole paper on it um was an
attempt to look at all this all these
things that we
we've really been discussing today
honestly and say like
if we get beyond the sort of legal
questions everybody always jumps to the
legal questions how do we you know pass
a law to do this or that
um and instead look at the technology
side and like
is there a way that that technology can
help
drive the good part of this forward and
is there a technological approach that
um is better than jumping to a legal
approach and so the idea here is that if
we rethink like a lot of the problems
and the paper goes into a lot of detail
so i'm not gonna describe the whole
thing but like
you know um if we look at a lot of the
concerns that people have and this is
again on both sides and some of this is
certainly
legitimate is what they're really
worrying about is how much power
these companies have to make these
decisions or not to make these decisions
right and that's really the complaint
that you have just a few of these
companies
and they're very big um and you know so
that leads some people down the path of
saying like antitrust is the answer and
i
and because of the nature of information
flows
and uh and network effects i don't think
antitrust solves anything
you don't break up facebook like you
broke up the telephone company to baby
bells you can't have like a
west coast facebook and east coast
facebook that just that doesn't work
so you know what i was trying to do was
say like is there a technological
approach that would be better for
everybody including the companies
themselves
um and it is you know thinking about
uh uh you know social media or or
other websites as as a protocol and the
example i use is sort of the simplest
way to understand about it and this is
not
it's not a perfect analogy but the
easiest to understand is to compare it
to email
right emails built on a bunch of
standards smtp
imap there's a couple other things in
there
and so anyone can set up you can set up
your own email server if you want
or anyone can set up their own email
service and then you can communicate
with anybody else's email you're not
locked in so if you use gmail
you're not locked into that if you use
outlook you know microsoft's email
you're not logged into that you can set
up your own
and you know you can communicate and
that also means that if you want to
switch it's very easy to switch you
don't lose
access to all of your contacts and you
can see like different providers can
come and offer different services you
know gmail is now
you know certainly the biggest and most
commonly used email provider
and they jumped into the space and they
offered something better which was a
much better interface for email
and a huge amount of storage at the time
but others have jumped in so now like
protonmail is really popular among the
sort of privacy set because they're
they're much more privacy protective
and yet you know you can use any of
these and you can communicate with other
people and in fact you can
do other things with it so you can have
a gmail address but not actually use
gmail's
system you can actually pump it into
into your own client if you use like uh
mozilla i forget what mozilla's email
client is like thunderbird
under bird used to yeah anyway yeah yeah
now i'm getting all nostalgic
yeah yeah but but there's all different
things that you can do
and and you know so there are some some
really nice things there
if you think about it that way in that
um it enables for more competition even
if you have like a large player google
is still a large player
and they still have probably the the
majority of folks who are using email
services but if you're uncomfortable
with them it's easy to leave right
without losing access to everybody that
you talk to and in fact you
you can very easily continue to
communicate with them you can move all
your email out
you can do all these different things um
and to some extent i actually think that
also
makes the companies themselves act
better it's it becomes a sort of
competitive element there
you know because if google realizes
they're losing lots of people
you know and early on there were all
these concerns that like google was
snooping on
on gmail well that was the price that
you paid for gmail was that a bot
would read keywords uh in the original
iteration right
the original sweep for keywords and then
uh post ads basically right but they
moved away from that yes like people
forget that but they
moved away from that because they
realized that that was that was
problematic and they were losing
people to it and so it's like a
market-based technology-based approach
to actually allowing for real
competition so if you could build like a
social media platform
that was the same thing that was a
protocol that anyone's like facebook
could have their own implementation
twitter could have their own
implementation
somebody else could have their own
implementation and if you felt that like
you didn't trust mark zuckerberg or you
didn't like the way he was doing things
then move elsewhere and you could still
communicate with the people who did want
to stay on facebook
but you didn't have to give in to their
specific rules so
i mean this is kind of a way of either
maintaining or re-uh
reinvigorating a notion of a
decentralized internet right which was
what the internet was kind of sold as
yes that it was a you know a collection
of computers or
printing presses or however you know you
wanted to conceive of it
um i i guess one of the questions i have
is
um you know i at the the paper protocols
not platforms there'll be a link
somewhere on
on the podcast page for this to that um
it's really fascinating thoughtful but
we do like our walled gardens don't we
yeah this is one of the things you talk
about is that you know the protocols
were there and and in many ways the
internet and certainly the web is kind
of based
on top of these but we kind of like the
walled garden and people made fun of
america online um you know because it
had this really i mean it was an
incredibly
you know well-rendered you know mall
that you online that you could go to
and then it had to you know let people
pass through to the internet and then it
was kind of over
but now facebook is essentially a walled
garden one of the things we like about
it or even the google suite of services
because when it's a platform that is
under the you know a single kind of
commanding
intelligence everything tends to work
better apple people love apple products
yeah i think less because they think
they're good but it's like they know
it's pain in the ass
if you use one thing that's not apple
apple makes it really hard
amazon yeah yeah i but you know
what what are the like why would a a
a company like an apple like amazon
uh you know facebook why would they ever
give up their wallet gardens that have
you know in in some cases billions of
people who are happy to hang out there
yeah i mean it's it's tricky but there
are a couple of things so one
is and the thing that you didn't even
mention of course is the other benefit
of the walled garden is that
you can often you know extract extra
rents that way yeah
sort of locks people in uh you know from
from uh
from a profit perspective right you know
there's there's clear value there
so but part of my argument is honestly
like this whole debate that we've had
for all this time that we've been
talking is becoming more and more costly
for these companies right the fact that
they are constantly being raked over the
coals the fact that they are constantly
being
called before congress to have you know
democrats yell at them about not doing
enough and republicans yelling about
them about doing too much at some point
that becomes incredibly costly facebook
has hired what like 30
000 content moderators at this point i
was going to say that's how we're
getting out of the pandemic
it's like everybody you don't have to
leave your house but you have to do
content moderation
on your neighbor it's
that's i mean that's the joke right the
future of work is just we're all going
to be moderating each other's content
but but like that that becomes
increasingly costly and at some point
there is there's reason to believe that
companies might say you know what you
know what is a better approach is to go
back to these earlier principles of the
internet where
we push that power to the ends and we
don't we don't have it all be
centralized
and that doesn't mean that each of us
has to be you know making all of our
decisions do
you know it shouldn't be every day i
wake up and say do i want to hear donald
trump today do i have you know
do i want to last but you know we can we
can build sort of
you know trusted you know trusted
sources trusted communities
i can say like you know i i want to see
the the the people that reason thinks is
important or i want to see
who eff thinks is important or you know
or whoever else we can we can set up
different things and different rules
and so for the companies i think it it
gets to the point where they recognize
like
maybe we're better off not having this
because it becomes a liability in and of
itself
um and already you know twitter has
indicated that they're interested and in
fact they cited my paper
uh in saying that they're now exploring
this idea of trying to build a more
decentralized twitter
um and sort of you know in effect take
take themselves out of the walled garden
business
and that that is a process that's that's
ongoing i think they're going to have
some announcements about that soon
um but it's you know it's interesting
that i think
companies recognize that i think that um
you know the other thing that may happen
and i don't know that this is like
twitter's thinking on it
is i think that a lot of companies who
are not facebook may recognize that the
only way to defeat facebook
is to embrace this kind of approach
which is the kind of thing that is
harder for facebook to approach
and then you may have sort of two
internets one of which is facebook
and then one of which is the more open
uh
protocols based approach that lots of
companies embrace and i think that's a
real possibility too uh
to close out um could you uh
predict you know the i don't you know
let's say the next uh
two years before midterm elections or
something there
seems to be a renewed interest in in
antitrust particularly against tech
giants uh this is something that
elizabeth
warren talked a lot about and joe biden
seemed kind of open to
um you see you know the weird kind of uh
you know mirror version among uh people
like ted cruz and josh hawley who are
also
talking about possibly trying to turn
certain types of platforms into public
utilities essentially
um you know what do you what how do you
think this is going to play out um
over the next couple of years are we
going to see more and more attempts by
the government to kind of dictate
um you know tech i don't want to say
tech policy but
you know the way platforms actually are
um zuckerberg mark zuckerberg i
i think i lost the note but i mean in
july he said something like we don't
want to be arbiters of the truth
we want to be you know kind of a place
where people can come and
scream at each other for you know 20
hours a day
um he's kind of changed his tune lately
as of other people like
um you know and i think you know a real
deficiency among a kind of um
conventional libertarian thinking is
that is to only think about government
as
as the source of power and you know and
that government is always there always
bad
what we're in now is a world where we
see i mean it's kind of a neil
stephenson novel where
there are you know there are governments
quasi governments corporate governments
marauders
everybody you know there's a lot of
power circulating
how do you are you are you excited or
exhausted
by the thought of you know covering tech
for
another six weeks much less two years uh
well i'm definitely exhausted yeah
there's no way not to be exhausted at
this point um
you know my there's stuff that's going
to happen i think the anti-trust cases
um are interesting um frankly
like reading through the details i think
they're somewhat weak um
and based on the way antitrust law works
i you know maybe they'll get a win but
but you know a win would be a fine um
or or a useless breakup you know like i
don't think any of these
even if the the antitrust cases succeed
which i i would you know i would give
them maybe a 40
chance of succeeding you know it's oh
but if awesome whatsapp is broken off of
facebook the world will be
so totally different right yeah right
it's so
so you know to me i don't think that
that approach is going to work i don't
think any of the
attempts to regulate uh to reform or
repeal 230
are you know even if they're successful
um they're not going to have the impact
that people want and and that's that's
sort of
a big part of my problem and you know a
big part of why i
am exhausted you know i i i feel like
very few people are thinking through you
know i think for a lot of people
it's it's punitive right they don't like
facebook they don't like twitter they
don't like mark zuckerberg they don't
like jack dorsey
um they don't like jeff bezos uh and so
they
they it's it's about you know just
causing pain for these companies and
they think that that's going to
magically fix stuff
and that's not true and in fact like you
know i keep trying to point out to
people you look like
facebook was the first company that said
we're okay with reforming 230.
we're we're okay with that because they
will be right it'll be it's an
anti-competitive move on their part
it will limit the amount of competition
that they face and in fact like
sheryl sandberg just yesterday from when
we were talking
gave this this talk where she was like
we're the only company
that can stop the you know the q and on
crazy people from uh from communicating
so basically like give us all the power
you know it's like shut down the parlors
and the other sites
and just let facebook handle it's like
that's that's much more scary to me
than any of these other discussions and
so do you think that'll happen
um or do you think that that also is is
an unlikely outcome
i i think that that that
um you know the reform discussions for 2
30 are going to continue and i think
facebook will be a part of them and
we'll try and drive the conversation
in a way that they're happy with and
that is harmful to competitors i think
that's
that's almost definitely going to happen
um you know the one thing that i
i hope happens this time and i think is
already happening is that a lot of the
sort of you know what i would call
second-tier companies not
the the facebook and googles of the
world are recognizing that like
facebook is not on their side right in
this debate and that they need to be
present
um and that they're having these
discussions and sort of trying to argue
like
why section 230 is actually really good
for competition i mean we did the study
um you know on the the copia think tank
stuff we did a study a couple years ago
that
that looked at um you know data on
whether or not 230 and laws like 230
help create more competition and it and
we found that there was like
much greater investment and we looked at
like uh
230 versus the dmca we looked at u.s
versus europe and we looked at a few
countries where
like their laws changed you know whether
the law changed or there was a big court
case that changed the interpretation of
the law
and the more 230 like you were
the higher investment there was and when
you moved away from that you
decreased investment into internet
startups
um and so like 230 is a method for
getting more competition so i fear that
like pulling back from that we're
actually going to limit competition
and and limit a more you know sort of
market-oriented approach to this
do you worry at all that european kind
of
protocol or european um laws and
kind of traditions conventions are they
going to
you know the internet weirdly is still
you know kind of a u.s centric
apparition um you know or the european
the the way europe is going is that is
that a model to follow or is it
something to run away from
europe's a real risk i mean you know i
think europe is getting to the point
that we're
much more likely to create a fragmented
and fractured internet
than before i mean we already have some
of that with like china has sort of
walled off its own internet
but europe is getting to the point the
eu you know i should be
specific um is getting to the point
where they've passed a bunch of laws
recently and have a few others that
they're working on
um all of which are i think extremely
dangerous and
and very very worrisome and um
even when they're done in good faith for
what they believe are good reasons are
very very short-sighted
about how the technology works how the
internet itself works
and are going to create massive
unintended consequences and we've
already seen some elements of this
with like the right to be forgotten
which has been a a ridiculous
um tool for for outright you know
blocking of speech
um you know gdpr and and their privacy
rules which have
again sort of like locked in the big
companies and given them tremendous
benefit
and sort of wiped the map clear of
smaller competitors
we have the new copyright directive that
are coming into play that are going to
be
hugely problematic for a whole bunch of
companies in the eu
you know it's getting to the point where
i think internet companies some of them
are going to say it's just not worth it
to do business in the eu at all anymore
and we might get a very separated you
know fragmented internet which i think
would be
a real loss um yes it certainly would be
a final
topic and i apologize for keeping you on
as long as
but i'm enjoying myself i hope you are
um no um
what about encryption um because you
know this
is again um you know uh joe biden who
who i you know has been in office since
the second
washington administration essentially
there's a long history and stuff but
he's talking about a domestic terrorism
law
going back to the 90s one of the big
issues that has kind of faded was
whether or not encryption should be
legal or not and you know obviously we
know you know the
intelligence services all hate and end
encryption and things like that
that is kind of being dragged into a lot
of conversations now because you know
the boogaloo boys and whoever yeah
are using encryption um and you know
simultaneously they can't be allowed to
meet
in public you know in public places like
facebook
because they will radicalize people but
then we
need to make sure that they're not
meeting anywhere you know etc i mean it
gets very complicated
um but do you worry about encryption
encryption becoming a battle again
yeah and in fact i think that's a big
concern it's connected to all this right
i mean like
you know with with everything that's
happened with parlor and and other
platforms lately
you know yeah obviously you know i mean
i think people said that that
signal downloads and telegram downloads
both our encrypted messaging services
are at an all-time high because people
are moving there and so
the the encryption debate is about to
get very loud again and i
i want to throw in one point that you
said the intelligence services all hate
anton encryption that i don't think is
true it's the law enforcement folks who
really really hate
encryption within the intelligence
services you have sort of a mixed bag
because you have a whole bunch of people
in the intelligence community who are
like
we rely on end-to-end encryption and so
you've had
you know intelligence officials sort of
pushing back on on the attack on
unintended encryptions usually law
enforcement and and you know the fact is
that
that is also they're being incredibly
misleading right
what they really want is just easier
access but but like
today we have more ability to speak than
ever before law enforcement has more
ability to find out
more information on on any sort of
criminal activity than they ever have
before and even people who are using
encryption
tend to be really bad at it especially
you know the kind of
people criminals are not the smartest
yeah that's
awesome that's the biggest you know like
i hate arthur conan doyle for convincing
all of us
that criminals are smart when they're
right there are a couple of
uh grades below professor moriarty for
sure
yes and and encryption to use in a way
that is
is is as protective as people seem to
think it is is very difficult there are
people who can do it
but they are not your everyday criminals
and in fact like you know
uh i i know some of the people who
created the original pgp
you know encryption for email who don't
use pgp encryption for email because
like yeah that's too difficult
it's it's not that easy to use this
stuff and it's certainly not easy to use
well
and all of the examples that we have is
like you're still giving off so much
information
so like yes i do think there will be a
fight about it and i think
it's worth watching and we should be
concerned about how that fight plays out
um and i think you know i think there
are real reasons why
law enforcement should be paying
attention to where people are going
within these encrypted messengers
but like i don't think that like
uh the excuse that like oh we have to
get rid of encryption in some way
because
you know bad people are gonna do bad
stuff with encryption
i don't think that holds any weight um
on a absolutely final note but a
positive one too you wrote
sometimes semi-recently imagine how much
worse the pandemic would be without the
internet
yeah coming into a year ago
people hated tech they hated the
internet on some level and obviously
that still
kind of holds but it's also true that um
you know the past year what is would
have been so much worse as bad as it's
been
without the internet um you know uh
say something good about that i mean
it's stunning how quickly people forget
like how much the internet has has made
the this pandemic you know bearable and
survivable
for a huge segment of the population now
that's not to leave out there are a ton
of people who
you know have been you know decimated
and just destroyed by the pandemic
and the inability to work or or other
situations
but the fact is that there's so much
stuff that that could not have been done
you know away from other people before
that is now possible
because of the internet you know the
ability to
have this conversation on zoom obviously
like you know
i had you zoom before the pandemic but
almost everybody i know had never even
heard of zoom before the pandemic
and and like you know the fact that like
so many companies you know silicon
valley was like the first one to shut
down and send all their workers home
and realize like we can we can do this
we can all work remotely and it works
okay
the fact that you know everybody has has
the ability to do that you know the fact
to shop online
so many people like my parents who are
you know
up there in age have discovered how to
shop online and realize like it's much
safer
if i you know use costco delivery or
instacart or whatever
um that's amazing and i and i think that
you know we uh
you know because it's here and because
we're used to it we've sort of forgotten
about how amazing it is
and how much it's really helped you know
if this pandemic had happened this way
even 10 years ago i think the disaster
level would have been much worse
just because of the lack of internet
infrastructure that we have today that
we can rely on to to make all of this
stuff possible
well that's a great note to end on i
want to thank mike masnick of tech dirt
for talking to the recent interview mike
thanks so much thanks for having me